okay we have a voicemail today the
voicemail a number of course is two one
nine two david p remember that you can
call the voicemail number anytime of day
you might recall a couple of months ago
we heard from a retired psychiatric
nurse who had some insights into donald
trump's possible condition she is back
on the voicemail line today there was
the suggestion from some viewers a week
or so ago that donald trump may be
suffering from tardive dyskinesia the
psychiatric nurse explains this is
unlikely let's take a listen hi david
this is Katherine retired psych nurse I
wanted you to know that
tardive dyskinesia is a result of
medications are used to treat psychosis
yes there were the first antipsychotic
meds around and they had terrible side
effects most of them are no longer in
use and also I noticed for a long time
that Donald Trump has extremely limited
range of motion in his neck you know he
can't turn his head to the side he kind
of turned his whole shoulder so I don't
know if that's related to anything but
it isn't try a dyskinesia which is
repetitive and voluntary movement and
its really a shame when people have that
and you don't usually see it anymore
so thanks very much I listen just show
off and take care all right always great
to hear from Katherine giving us
insights immediately it seems as though
we can we can write off this possibility
of tardive dyskinesia you know I have
noticed that Donald Trump does do that
thing where he will sort of brace on his
lectern at speeches and he will kind of
turn his entire sort of like from-from
the breastbone up when he looked to the
side and I'd never made much of it but
Katherine pointing out that that is a
little bit unusual that's uh always
great to hear from Katherine and it
seems to be continued mystery what
exhibit what is the full list of
conditions which may be afflicted Donald
Trump will we ever know not if Trump has
anything to say about it we've got a
great bonus show for you today
we
are going to talk about new laws coming
this year in 2020 various state laws
that you may find interesting we are
also going to talk about a Virginia
School District that is giving students
a day off one day off per year for what
they are calling civic engagement I
think this is fantastic
we will talk about it we will also talk
about the Hallmark Channel this was a
big controversy for a lot of
right-wingers the Hallmark Channel has
reversed its decision to pull a
commercial that has a same-sex couple in
it they initially made the decision to
pull it they've reversed the decision
and this is part of I hate using the
term culture war because it is a trumped
up term meant to create a particular it
has a very narrow meaning the way it's
used but there are cultural elements
that are important to what is going on
here which I want to discuss all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show two ways to get instant access to
the bonus show in 2020 number one become
a member we have some members who are
about to embark on their 10th years as
David Pakman show members embark on your
first year by signing up at join
pakman.com or make a pledge on patreon
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
I'll speak to you then